I'm still experiencing frequent panic attacks
from Lyme disease, brain inflammation, and low estrogen.
What are your thoughts on me trying some hypervere oxygen
treatments for the Lyme disease and breast cancer?
It hopes that it will help you rid of the panic attacks.
One concern I have is that I have read,
it can cause those with Lyme to hurt,
you have a hurt cyber reaction, the hurt's badly.
So, hypervere oxygen is oxygen under pressure,
which you're in an oxygen tank,
and it is highly beneficial for your brain.
It can kill Lyme disease,
and the reason why it went first
is if you had a current bacterial meaning,
so remember Lyme disease, by definition,
is a combination of lerelia vergodorfia bacteria,
and other co-infections.
Some of the other co-infections are virus,
not even bacteria,
and some of them are not gram-negative bacteria.
You get a, you get a hypercymer reaction from mainly
from the death of gram-negative bacteria,
because they have lipopolysaccharides in their cell membrane,
and when you liberate them by killing a lot of them quickly,
you can feel really it.
And so, that being said,
can hyperverecoxygen,
if you have a current birelia in your brain,
cause a hurt's saber?
Yes.
Well, how would I know that or not?
There's no test for that.
You can't do a lab,
or do I have birelia in my brain lab?
There Jesus can't.
If you did a birelia vergodorfia,
IgM antibody test,
and it was positive,
you could get a good clue that you have a current infection
of birelia,
but it doesn't mean that it's in the brain.
However, if you killed quickly,
you're better aware it is,
you could get a hurt's saber reaction anytime.
So, I would say,
I would say to go for it,
but do shorter sessions to begin with.
So, typically,
hyperverecoxygen treatment session
is going to be at least one hour, 60 minutes long.
Sometimes, depending on where you go,
it could be a 90-minute session
or even a two-hour session.
But typically, it's going to start with a 60-minute session.
If you tell the practitioner,
you're dilemma with live disease
that you want to start shorter,
there's no harm in doing only a 15-minute session.
Well, I'm going to just do a shorter session,
you know, three times a week or something,
and see how you tolerate it.
If you tolerate it well,
certainly a 15-minute session,
three times a week is going to cause a horrible live disease
that's going to, you know,
put you in a crippling position for a period of days.
That's going to be a shorted-up experience
that's not going to cause that much
like a polysaccharide liberation.
If you do have
merlea,
currently in your body.
Remember, many times, people with
chronic live disease
are suffering the effects
of the chronic live that may not
have living merlea in their body anymore.
That's the majority of the cases.
They are just dealing with autoimmune issues
that, you know, that
that the merlea left behind.
So they have antibodies to drill tissue.
They have to get microquiet primate,
et cetera, in the brain.
And they're dealing with those effects.
They may not have the existence of
current
merlea bacteria.
So if you tolerate the 15 minutes,
three times a week,
then go to 30 minutes.
Oh, I'm tolerating that well.
Then go up to 45 minutes.
You can work your way up
and make sure that you don't hurt.
That's a good way to do it.
The positive is is that
the
hyperbaric option is good for breast cancer.
It's good for your brain.
If you have antibodies to
neural tissue, it's really good for that.
It helps clear the brain.
It's only got positives,
except for that piece,
it could actually kill pathogens.
And if those pathogens are
grabbed negative bacteria,
it could hurt, of course.
So that's the thing you just got to go slow with.